If you had told me before I got into this
whole line of work that I'm doing,
that modeling was difficult
or at all arduous,
I would've laughed.
Hmm
I would've said, "What
are you talking about?
That looks like the
easiest job in the world."
But Sony, you'll back me up.
Yeah.
Whenever I've had to be
part of a photo shoot.
Yep.
And they want me to smile and they're,
you know they're taking
pictures for anything, any
Yeah.
Article or any kind of
publicity that I've been doing
over the 30 years that
I've been doing this,
I, there comes a point where I go "Damn."
Yeah
"This is not fun.
This is not fun the way
you'd think it would be fun."
It's, there actually is,
and I can't describe why
it's difficult, but it is.
I, I know, I don't know why it is either.
I just, I've, I've been doing it so long
that it's become like
second nature for me.
Mm hmm.
And, and when I work, I've
worked other jobs in my life.
Mm hmm.
So, I just compare that to
Yes.
Whatever else I've done.
And, and it, and it is easier,
I have to say, than you know,
working a minimum wage job or
during the pandemic I went tree planting.
So, that was super hard.
Wait, what was, what do you
mean you went tree planting?
How's that work?
It's like a job in Canada that you can do.
You can go up north and plant
trees for 9 cents a tree.
It's like peace work.
I, I wanted to do
something that was kind of
outside of modeling when
everything shut down.
And so yeah,
I went up north with my best friend and
That's so funny.
And we planted trees.
If I had to describe what's
the opposite of modeling,
I would say agriculture.
(group laughing)
I really would.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm not even joking, but,
well, first of all that
sounds like a very, I mean,
2000 trees a day, is that what
you do in this tree planting?
Close to, yeah.
But that was just me.
You know, some of the boys like,
some of the stronger
guys would plant 4,000.
Yeah. But half of those die.
They're not being careful.
So you'd make what, $180 a day?
Is that right?
Yeah, close to.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, but the other thing is.
Yeah.
You're planting trees,
which is such an amazing thing to do.
Yeah.
I mean, I, I, I think if everybody,
if they figured out a way
that everybody on earth
could plant like four trees a day.
Yeah.
Well, then we'd have to water them,
and we don't have the water.
Oh.
Okay. This is getting grim.
Well, anyway, I think it's
really great what you did.
I think it, I think that's very cool.
Thank You. Yeah.
I, I went a little crazy up there,
like because you're, you're,
you're in a piece of land
on your own for like eight hours a day.
So, you know, a helicopter
would fly by every day
and every day I'd make the same joke.
Like, Oh, there's my ride.
(group laughing)
And like each day it got
funnier and funnier and I
Wow, you guys are a lot alike.
You know what Molly?
(Conan laughing)
you're my, you're,
you're my kind of person.
Yeah.
You, you are a tall thin
redhead that loves to
make the same joke over
and over and over again
until it becomes funny only to you.
(group laughing)
God bless you, Molly.
You're my new hero.